what I want to do in this video is
convert this amount of kilometers into
meters and centimeters so we will first
start with the two kilometers and I
encourage you to now pause this video
and try to do this on your own well the
one thing that we know is that a
kilometer literally means 1,000 meters
so you could literally view this as two
two times 1,000 meters let me write that
down so this is going to be equal to two
times 1,000 meters which is equal to
2,000 meters if we wanted to convert the
11 kilometers into meters was the same
thing 11 kilometers this right over here
means 1,000 meters so you could think of
it as 11 times 1,000 meters so 11 times
1,000 is going to be 11,000 meters now
let's convert these distances into
centimeters and here we just have to
remember that one meter is equal to 100
centimeters let me write that down one
meter is equal to 100 centimeters and
that's because the prefix centi means
one hundredth another way you could
write it is that one centimeter is equal
to 100 one hundredth of a meter but here
we have a certain number of meters and
each of those meters are going to be
equivalent to 100 centimeters so we
could write if we wanted to write 2,000
meters as centimeters we could say well
we have 2,000 meters each of those are
going to be equivalent to 100
centimeters and so this is going to be
equal to 2,000 times 100 well that's
going to be 2 and since we're we have
the 3 zeros from the 2,000 and then
every time you multiply by 10 you're
going to add another 0 or you're going
to have another 0 at the end of it and
we're going to be at multiplying by 100
is equal to adding by 10 or multiplying
by 10 twice so we're going to have two
more zeros so this is going to be
200,000 centimeters now let's do the
same thing right over here with the
kilometers or there with the 11
kilometers which are 11,000 meters and
once again I encourage you to
the video and try to convert into
centimeters well same idea you have
eleven thousand meters
eleven thousand meters and each of them
are equivalent to 100 centimeters so
this is going to be 11 and let's see we
have one two three four five zeroes one
two three four five zeroes so this gets
us to 1 million 100,000 centimeters